hey i just wanted to share a tip um
and on a lot of people's computers
firefox the internet browser right here
takes a little longer than you'd like to
load
a simple solution for that is called
firefox
preloader and you can uninstall it
unload it reload it basically what it
does is loads a bunch of components of
firefox beforehand
and
now when you click on firefox it's it's
extremely fast look i'm exiting out of
it it's not in down it's not in my tray
but if i click on it here firefox owes
very fast it's very very quick
um
so i really really really recommend it
if you have enough ram right now
i have three gigs of ram on this laptop
and i'm using 1.8 gigs i'm using a lot
because of this
codec i'm using
um
let me see
it opens up at all
oh it's behind it no it's not yes it is
cam studio lossless codec
i get decent fps but look at that
processor so um if you have enough ram
then i would really suggest firefox
preloader it opens quickly it opens
almost as fast as safari safari is a
little quicker
but i would totally recommend using
this firefox preloader
um
so good luck
oh well i should show you where to get
it so uh
open up your internet browser whatever
that may be and type in
oh first go to google
i'll type in firefox reloader i hope you
can see this
the first one that comes up
is sourceforge.net
it says it is a firefox preloader
utility that's designed to load parts of
firefox into the memory to improve
startup time so i'm clicking on it
uh
sourceforge.net of course right at the
top is your big green download arrow
click it
installation is really simple and if you
have windows vista open up menu
just type in firefox and preloader is
one of your programs
um
of course if i click on it it'll say
it's already running
so
that's what it is that's how you get it
um
yeah so i hope you like